I shot a movie in New York 7 years ago
on the streets whatever and it was so
wonderful to to rap and then walk home
feels more like a creative exercise I
guess well the city has the and they
always use the cliche of the energy but
it does have the energy right it simply
does because everybody's on top of each
other right I mean look at it all the
buildings on top of each it's different
from La La is spread out you get the car
back in 1971 when I learned to drive I
had to learn to drive out there it was
wonderful it's made for cars yeah you
know and you just turn the music up
you're uh your Edge rots out there
though yeah it tended to but luckily I
was able to do films like taxi driver
and then right mainly because they saw
main streets and they wanted dairo and
myself together on that film